we're back well and truly in complex
number land I mean we have been all
along you just didn't know before the
kind of quite see the implications yet
but I promise we're gonna get there then
I'm gonna keep a close eye on my watch
now that had easy complete let me fill
it in for you first by explaining what's
going on what do we know about complex
numbers so far and what can we do with
them well we've been thinking that
basically as quantities as values right
we learn to that complex number
arithmetic we learnt about adding and
subtracting squaring multiplying taking
square roots and so on right so in other
words we've been manipulating that with
the arithmetic algebraic rules that
you're already familiar with from the
real numbers okay but here comes the
important huge idea actually that really
is why complex numbers are not just
interesting but why are they powerful
okay because complex numbers like it's
just right over here because complex
numbers have this sum this duality to
them okay there's the real part and
there's the imaginary part in other
words they have to genuinely separate
components right to separate components
have you wondered why I said the real
part is X and the imaginary part is y
want those letters okay in fact in some
textbooks you will find them using our
as their as their default instead of X
plus iy they will choose a plus I B and
there's nothing wrong with that a and B
are just real numbers and you know you
make them whatever you like the reason
why I've chosen to designate them x and
y and why other people do as well is
because I'm trying to see the parallel
between if you've got any two separate
components right whether they're X's and
Y's or temperature and sunscreen or
distance and time if you've got two
quantities that are related you can
graph them against each other on a plane
right these two separate components the
X and the y can represent the
coordinates of a point on a plane
right as opposed to real numbers which
I'm not points on a plan
they are points on a line right the
number line we're familiar with this
every single real number that exists now
I need a new color every single real
number that exists can be plot on a
number line right they're all there so I
could call this the real number line by
complex numbers they introduce something
extra something different something
which is a second separate quantity so
if it's a second separate quantity it
deserves its own separate axis right so
in addition to the real number line
which is one axis I'm going to have an
imaginary number one an imaginary axis
okay now what we're gonna have here is
the representation of our complex
numbers as points on here right so for
instance if I take a number like 3 plus
I there's a real bit and there's an
imaginary bit okay how big is the real
bit 3 right so normally if I just had
the real number 3 I'd go 1 2 3 and
that's where I put 3 but there's three
plus I how big is the imaginary compar
pop component the answer is 1 right um I
is the actual measure proper the size of
it is 1 how many eyes are there there's
one right so if that's the Y component
I'm going to go up 1 unit so there's 3
and there's one okay that point there is
what own core is ed1
right according to I'm just give me as
my exam right here ah yes it's exactly
right so so what is this number here
it's 1 and not I right because I'm
talking like on this axis you know if I
have my say a time axis right I would
have the youth of the numbers 1 2 3 4
now there might be seconds or hours or
minutes but the units are not part of
the axis right then what I sort of put
onto
and in the same way the unit's here are
still real numbers why is a real number
but what is adding on is I how many eyes
do I have so there's n 1 it's 3 plus I
so is a coordinate system ok now a
couple of things to those we've been
used to calling two lines are
perpendicular angles with area man we've
been used to calling that the Cartesian
plane okay this is not the Cartesian
plane the Cartesian plane has an x axis
where real numbers and has a y axis with
real numbers okay but this is not to
real axes that are put together it's a
real axis and an imaginary axis so this
is not the Cartesian plane this is the
complex plane okay now the the
mathematician sort of pioneered the use
of this has popularized it was a guy
named Laura bear again I think I'm
Habakkuk pronouncing that completely
wrong the important part is his surname
so this is also cool when you actually
put some numbers on it
this is called an Argand diagram just
our Gantt diagram we'll talk about that
we're not ready for that yet but we will
talk about that shortly
it isn't really ever called that name
though that's more about how do you
represent a system affordable if by now
thinking about complex of numbers as not
just numbers but like points in a plane
right what I can now do is not just
think in terms of arithmetic we do
complex arithmetic before right now I
can think about complex numbers and
their geometry because points in a plane
can be understood in terms of the shapes
that they make and the lines that have
folded on it or not so coming over here
now this allows us to take all of the
various pieces of reading we've been
doing with copics numbers so far adding
subtracting multiplying another load and
it allows us
- geometrically interpret them I kind of
tease this before I was like okay we can
have couple examples we can work out
what Z 1 plus Z 2 is equal to what does
it mean what is it actually telling us
what is the sum of those complex numbers
and their relation to these complex one
stop it
what I'm gonna do is just with these two
examples right we're gonna rehearse all
of those arithmetic operations that we
did before and we're going to try and
superimpose them or to our new scheme
for understanding complex numbers okay
so here's their 1 and Z 2 what was the
first thing that we learn to do with
complex numbers we would learn to add
them right which also applies
subtraction all kids of that so firstly
Z 1 plus Z 2 ok now we've learned when
you're adding complex numbers you just
take the real parts and you take the
imaginary parts and you deal with them
separately yes
so what's the suburbs in ones that you
just read it off thank you okay now if I
know that this is a number this is a
number and the representation points now
that this is a point as well okay so
let's drop a new set of axes now let's
put all three points onto our set of
axes let's let's not just write these
complex numbers let's draw what have you
established we just I've just plotted z1
and z2 just like I had um just like I
have said one over here and now that I
said 1 plus said 2 is 4 plus 6i I just
went 1 2 3 4 on the real axis 1 2 3 4 5
6 on the imaginary axis so there's my 4
plus 6i up in the corner now
geometrically what's going on here okay
it won't become a bit clearer if not
only do I include the points but if I
include the relationships and intervals
between the points okay so I can say
well if that said 1 2 get 2 set 1 from
the origin I went three across and one
up which gave me this
that's zip 1 2
that one to get to Zedd - I went one
across in five up right so that's yeah
okay now when you start to put those two
lines in you start to see or we'll get
to that in time you start to see they're
kind of lines missing from our diagram
right for example see this line this
integrals if it went from the oranges at
one that same interval is on the diagram
somewhere else I just haven't drawn it
where else is it it's between yeah B -
how'd you articulate it where where can
I find this interval where else is like
anyone else we'll never have a shot yeah
that's do it so yeah so this like you
write this into motion this is all yeah
you can see it it's right here it's the
same interval right I shouldn't be that
surprised really because I had to go
right I added on why don't I add on BRE
this way
three yeah three this way and what up
which is three plus I write in the same
way I've got this zip - interval I've
got it over here all right so what if I
made I've made a parallelogram it may be
a rhombus if Z 1 and Z 2 of the if those
two intervals have the same length but
in my case they do not so what I've got
here is this kind of arrangement right
now this in fact has a name because
we've made a parallelogram with addition
ok this is in fact called via the
parallelogram law I know right it's all
parallel walls okay